now how's it going everybody my name is
Matt you're watching a video in code
tectum tutorials if you're new here
welcome welcome to the channel here we
do all sorts of code stuff and various
tutorial stuff and basically whatever I
feel like doing because I'm a solo
person who runs this channel but today
today is a vlog on my game engine I've
been making him or OpenGL which
apparently is what everybody that
programs in the world is doing because
when I searched online for there's a
million people with their own engines so
I feel a little weird because of that
but that is not the reason I started I
started on my own accord before I had
any idea anyone else was trying to do
such a thing and this is uh what vlog
for sort of lost track anyway a lot of
things have happened since the last one
as you can see I've gotten some objects
rendering some little pixelated weird
and that's because I've scaled it up the
time and it's not the highest quality
texture but I just want to do a quick
walkthrough of kind of where this is at
and let's see last time I showed off the
whole github history of a bunch of
different versions and this time is more
like just some kind of planning and
where we're going kind of thing because
I don't want to say too much I know I
said I was gonna make it public and I
just don't feel quite ready it will be
eventually though it's night it's not
gonna be forever so I'm just gonna show
you where it's at in the test I have
setup basically and also I guess I'll
note the changes since last video let's
see as I mentioned I was on this face to
branch warm sort of redoing a lot of
these stuff in the engine and I didn't
mean to put them behind okay so here is
just a ton of stuff that has happened
since when was that last video I don't
know I've kind of lost track maybe it
was the end of November or something
yeah it was somewhere around here so
it's been it's been about well it's
December 24th now I've done all these
changes some of these changes were we're
massive some were little but I've
basically added lights rendering I've
started to support multiple shaders and
it's now kind of to the point where I
just need to make bunch of shaders and
light logic
add in some more improvements on my 3d
objects so they can render in different
ways the main goal is really to get PVR
lighting working I'm a little ways away
from that and I also want to get physics
and colliding working in the engine so
you might be a little confused now like
okay it's an engine what'll I what do I
do
well that I will go ahead and kind of
show you so here's all the engine files
these are kind of hidden behind the
scene type of files I mean obviously
when you're working on the engine
they're not but if you're for instance
deciding okay I want to build a game
with this engine what do I do
that's where you would kind of look at
the test functions and see how you can
put together the engine files in a way
that makes sense but basically what you
do and let's say I look at my main here
so my main when my main runs I I just
call Retta run all tests and that's
pretty much what I'm doing here just to
make sure things are working as I'm
building them and continue to work so I
have a pretty big set of test cases
where I'm using a lot of stuff in my
engine and wow this runs throw'em that
is an engine base case I'll walk through
these super quick and maybe it'll give
you a bit of an understanding so the
engine base case is just a function that
instantiates the engine and it's the run
function and of course the run function
does all the stuff for the engine to
stay in a while loop to closes and
that's all does it's a very base case so
this should work and then we go to the
the next one we run which is the engine
functions base case so this populates
all the functions in the engine now this
is sort of a weird thing I don't weird
it's actually I like it I don't think
it's weird so the engine is full of
lists of functions that happen and you
can add or remove them as needed and
when we run this engine it basically
goes through all of these via update
render update
there's an update with Delta time and
render and update without Delta time so
it goes through all of those on each run
so basically it's up to the developer or
the person using the engine to populate
all these as would make sense and did
comp their own logic and that's why
you'll start to see a little bit in
function demo one and two this base case
just populates them all with basically a
sea out that says what it does or says
where it's at and it's just kind of an
example to make sure it all actually
runs and goes through all the loops as
intended so this just text tests all
those the next test I have is just a
pause it all it really does is Stan she
ate the engine say it's paused and
changed the clear color and then it just
sits there until you close the window
basically there's really nothing going
on of course it's going through its main
loop but there's no functions that are
populated in that loop so it's basically
just keeping timing and going until you
close it so that's basically what paws
does and by keeping timing I mean yeah
the time is still ticking on the game
itself so it's not a true pause although
it maybe could be I just named a pause
because it looks like it doesn't nothing
so functions 1 or 2 is where it gets a
little more interesting this is where we
start to add in movement to the engine
and a skybox and I have preferred
defaults now these are just things that
I would repeat over and over if I didn't
make them their function of their own
because they're very common things to do
like obviously I want movement so how
about why not God movement while you're
building the game this is just the
first-person movement that lets you fly
around the level and see what you're
doing when you're building for defaults
I think right now just changes the
render distance and window size so I can
call that if I want to be that real
quick so there enough little test drive
folder and Driver do not repeat yourself
these are functions for that so as you
can see I have instantiated some static
objects here and I've added some things
to the functions of course these add
added some things to the functions
that's why they need to know about the
engine and they of course do it
reference so they can add things some of
these functions is just some base stuff
this is like this sets up first-person
movement first-person cursor and handles
some flying stuff that's that's kind of
the big one so I'll use that over and
over again and eventually I have new
ones for actual more player movement but
that's a nice one for just building
stuff to begin with and let's see
function demo - it's just basically
another world I once again add the god
movement before defaults but as you see
I am using the shader manager on these
in this one where's the shader manager
this one has a 3 light shader and this
one has a no light shader so there's no
light being calculated and the shader
manager can kind of switch between them
as you draw the sword at the point and
you can come up with your own logic on
how to do that but the shader manager
will let you load in however many
shaders you want and use them as
necessary on your objects depending on
how you want them drawn so right now I
have a couple just a couple but there's
actually one of the skybox - that's
abstracted into the skybox class now you
never really see and if you want more
later for like your UI that's something
I'll have to either he could build that
or I could make it part of the engine
which I will later but I think it makes
sense to do in some way or some form but
also I want users to be able to make
their own interface if they want because
you know if you're using the one from
the engine all the time it's gonna it's
gonna look cheesy or whatever you know
it's gonna look the same all the time so
you can't really necessarily style it
but I haven't got to it yeah so maybe
I'll add an option to style I don't know
yet and that's it I'll go ahead and run
it you can see all the stuff happen live
so the first test there is just testing
a bunch of models and see if they
actually load looks like they look fine
then it pops up a window will fall along
in the main here I'll show you oh just
wearing the code were actually at you
get my window back up here
Oh God I just do I just drug something
over there glitch something out alright
move this down somewhere you can see it
I'm here I guess get this window up here
so this is just the engine base case
don't do anything just sits here of
course this was all the test model over
him and did first now we're doing base
case and when I close this window and
see oops I just friggin launched Firefox
when I close this window it'll go to the
next one which is the test engine pause
or no I'm sorry this is the all
functions loop case and let's see here
will bring this up and as you can see
it's going through and it's spitting out
the happenings if I put my mouse in here
you can see the pointer change there's
some things I need edited there because
it's sort of set up from the engine to
be first-person only so I need to make a
few modifications to make it so that
it's you can actually click places if
you don't want to be in Reverse person
and it registered properly but right now
it's kind of made to move a first-person
camera and if I move my mouse wheel
you'll see the X&Y stuff change on that
I guess it's only 1 and negative 1
interesting I can get it to negative 2
for a second it looks like there might
be a slight glitch in that as it seems
to keep changing I'm not entirely sure I
might need to revisit that but anyway
that's the whole point of this test is
to see if things are working as intended
and okay let's go the next one the
engine pause this one literally does
nothing but sit here
now we get to function demo 1 which
loads in some objects and some light you
can see a point light it's actually
underneath this little spinning object
we've got a rotate test there there's
the spotlight
it says pointing at that building and
there is a another base light - that's
like a constant like you can't hardly
tell but these objects look a little
dark because they're not fully lit from
the directionally so there are three
lights in the scene and it's basically
just testing that and there's a donut in
the sky
so let's go on to the next one so I can
hit escaped get my mouse I built that in
and now we're on to the next one this
next one is the one I started out on
it's a very big scene it's just loading
in several different objects it's not
loading in any lighting so it's doing a
no lighting shader and that's why
everything just looks like it's real
value and then these are just some stuff
I goofed around with on blender there
nothing good or spectacular obviously
I'm just testing to make sure they
actually load so another thing I want to
do that I haven't quite supported yet
Wow I won't talk about that
nevermind that's it that's it so on the
next one I'll talk about more if you
want to support the series give this
video like consider helping out through
patreon if you really want to see it
accelerate a little faster this is
something I do in my spare time for free
and that's just kind of how it is right
now and unless other people take
interest in it or I make some awesome
game off of it or tutorials based on it
I don't know where it's going to go
exactly I'm just going to keep working
on it so let me know what you think and
if you have any questions let me know
hope you guys all have a good holiday
season
whatever it means to you we can ask for
is that it's better than the last and
I'll see you guys in the next episode
peace out